je veux refaire Marignan ici à angoise
vous voulez qu'on voie et qu'on pèse la
gloire et l'horreur de la guerre nous
sommes en 1518 François 1 est roi de
France pour les neus de sa cousine
Madeleine il demande à son grand ami
Léonard de Vincy d'organiser un
spectacle mais ce qu'il veut avant tout
c'est reconstituer sa victoire à
Marignan 3 ans plus tôt symbole de son
règne glorieux je pense que je vais bien
m'amuser parce que il faut remettre en
place tous les soldats revoir les strat
guerre moi je suis aussi un peu un
stratège puis j'ai inventé des machines
de guerre je vous le rappelle et je veux
que tu me dises que tu feras pour moi
ton am pourquoi il a demandé à Léonard
de l'aider à faire ça pourquoi tout ça
et en fait c'est parce que pour le pour
le roi François c'est une opération de
communication peut-être la première dans
l'histoire de France et qui a fonctionné
à merveille puisque 500 ans après 1515
Marignan c'est dans toutes les têtes un
jour de fête agrémenté de jout
chevalresque d'un grand B et
mais ce que les spectateurs attendent
surtout c'est cette reconstitution de la
bataille de Marignan de 1515 de jours de
bataille opposant les Suisses et les
troupes de François 1 et un terrible
bilan de 16000
morts véritable chef de guerre vous vous
jetez dans la m et au soir du deè jour
de combat vous remportez sur les Suisses
une victoire é plus de 300 figurants et
comédiens venus de toute l'Europe ont
investi durant
rour de près de 3500 specturséci le
spectacle même si pour certains les
dialog sont trop présents c'est sympa
c'est bien il y a des beaux personnages
beau costumes tout c'est magnifique la
mise en scène c'est bien ENF
je une grandee c'est festif c'est un
beau spectacle et puisil on passe un bon
moment ensemble commeoi 500 ans plus
tard marigne une Bata marante Mme sonire
est
ou quand même les dames